كيف اطلقت شركه تويتر خدمه اشتراك شهري
هذه الحصول على علامه التوثيق الزرقاء
بقيمتي ثمانيه دولارات ياتي هذا بعد ان
سرحت الشركه حوالي 50% من موظفيها في كل
انحاء العالم بحسب وثيقه داخليه وقال الى
ماستر مالك وتويتر ان القراره كان الخيار
الوحيد المتاحه لان المؤسسات تخسروا اربعه
ملايين دولار يوميا
واشار الى ان تويتر تشهد انخفاضا هائلا في
الارادات بسبب ضغوط على المعلمين
هذا انا ماسك فتح باب المكافات الماليه
لاصحاب المحتوى على المنصه وتحولها تحولها
الى مصدر تخملين
لمنشئه المحتوى
نقلت قناه ام بي سي نيوز الامريكيه مصادر
مطلعه قولها ان تصريح الموظفين الجماعي في
تويتر استهدف في المقام الاول الفرق
المسؤوله عن تتبع المعلومات المضلله مما
قد يعرقل قدره الشركه على حظر المحتوى
المحظور ويتسبب في فوضى خلال انتخابات
التجديد النصفي من هذه نقل موقع بوليتكو
عن شخص مقرب من شركه تويتر انه تم تصريحه
نصف فريق السياسه العامه في تويتر بما في
ذلك اعضاء الفريق المسؤول عن التحقق من
حسابات السياسيين وضف الموقع وانه منذ
شراء تويتر صار لهم ماسك على ان تظل
سياسات الشركه بشان اداره المحتوى
والمعلومات المضلله
ساريه